welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a no spoiler review of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness i was lucky this time to get
invited to the film's la premiere last
night i learned my eyes and skin do not
comply with natural light outside of the
blue dungeon and i spent the screening
scribbling so many notes for the
breakdown that my thumb is still blue
with ink so as i walked out of the
theater i was still processing and
couldn't really put my thoughts into
words now we do not normally review
movies here on new rockstars honestly
because i think most people don't need
my advice on whether or not to see a
movie and i think there are just so many
more interesting things to say about a
film beyond a numerical score but with
all the interesting hot takes coming
about this film i think it helps to go
into it with a healthy mindset now again
no spoilers in this review and my
friends tread carefully down there in
the comments and on social media until
you see the movie so some general
thoughts doctor strange in the
multiverse madness delivers on the
promise of the mcu's first true horror
film with director sam raimi bleeding
his signature horror into every frame it
is the mcu's most violent film by a long
shot the body count is high and you feel
every fatality which is something i have
always felt the mcu could use some more
of but the squeamish among you can relax
while raymie has earned his reputation
as a master of horror cinema his
approach to the genre always comes with
a smirk whether it's the violent
delights of bruce campbell's ash in the
evil dead series the shot and freud of
wanting the damn didn't drag me to hell
to get dragged to hell or even the
sudden jump scares in his spider-man
films the mcu is after all live-action
toys smacking into each other and it's
okay for them to have to spit out some
blood every now and then multiverse of
madness's strengths come from the extent
to which they allow sam raimi to
actually evolve the aesthetics rainey
and his cinematographer john matheson
let the camera glide bend distort and
superimpose in ways you have never seen
after the marvel studios fanfare evoking
something closer to the surrealist
montages of rosemary's baby danny
elfman's score surrounds us and binds us
with madcap evil that said the film also
totally works as a marvel studios even
whatever you may have seen or theorized
or speculated over the marvel tie-ins
and surprises will have you pinching
yourself and screaming yes while the
nerd sitting next to you scribbling a
notepad tells you to shut up personally
i was equally thrilled with the theories
we got right as i was with the stuff
that went in a very different direction
marvel's producers proved once again
that they have a more nuanced approach
to how far to go with the fan service
hats off to that forever hatted mr feige
screenwriter michael waldron brought his
multiverse world building expertise from
loki on disney plus as well as on rick
and morty and on every level he hides
subtle winks that make the future of the
mcu multiverse as bright as it is brutal
the script also widens the mcu lexicon
with a glossary of terms and dream
redefining concepts that for me have
always been the most crucial
contribution of doctor strange to this
whole universe the rules are set up in
the first act and then in the climax
flourish with demonic delight like all
mcu films at this point multiverse of
madness certainly rewards having done
the homework if you have time maybe
review one division in the 2016 doctor
strange film as well as the animated
what if series and to my surprise
avengers infinity war in fact without
going into more detail i would say
infinity war might be the most important
mcu film to watch before this movie but
this is all truly the climax who won
division most of us went into one of
vision framing it as a prelude series
for multiverse madness and despite
doctor strange saying in trailers that
he's not here to talk about west view
this movie is very much about what went
down in west view and it is at its
creepiest and most heartbreaking when it
dives back into that hex which brings me
to what i wanted to see more of in this
movie oh my god new rockstar stinks an
mcu movie wasn't perfect cancel this man
now breaking these things down is the
skill that the gods have called me to do
but do you have a specific skill that
you are trying to learn maybe it's even
one that could help your career like
graphic design or learning how to write
a business plan well skillshare the
sponsor of this video can help you
invest in yourself and your personal
growth in 2022. skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for anyone who loves
learning and wants to explore their
creativity and learn new skills from
photography and illustration to
gardening freelancing and more you can
find classes that will match your goals
and interests they've got a deep roster
of classes on animation design and
photography so you can transition from
just enjoying other people's content to
making your own skillshare is ad-free
and new premium classes are launched
each week the entire catalog is now
available with subtitles in spanish
french portuguese and german the first 1
000 of my subscribers to click the link
in the description or use my code new
rockstars will get a one month free
trial of skillshare so you can start
exploring your creativity today now on
to some stuff that i wish we saw more of
dr strange's multiverse behind us maybe
it's the place wand division now
occupies in our hearts but dr strange
and the multiverse madness might have
been better framed as the scarlet witch
in the multiverse of madness because
elizabeth olsen's wanda maximoff is the
broken heart driving this film and as we
do with mia farrow and rosemary's baby
or even elphaba and wicked i connected
far more with her than i did with dr
strange's relationship with christine
palmer or with his variants or with
america chavez i cannot wait to see
zochi gomez more in the mcu especially
when she's out from under strange's wing
but as written in this story the
character often comes off as more of a
plot function than a patient the msu's
chief surgeon feels an emotional drive
to save maybe it's just the next day and
i'm still overwhelmed by all the other
masters this movie serves maybe i'll
feel differently when i rewatch it but
at this moment i just feel like i never
wondered what the emotional stakes for
strange were in the 2016 film or even in
the best episode from what if episode 4
but in this movie things did feel at
times a bit disjointed with any movie we
always ask ourselves what is the core
dramatic relationship of this film in
this case is it about strange and
christine is it about strange in america
is it about strange in wanda is it about
strange in his other stranges strange in
the multiverse at different parts of the
movie the answer to the question changes
you may also see some griping about the
way this story treats wanda as a
cold-hearted villain arguably unaffected
by her experiences with vision and
wanavision but i would say wandavision's
post-credits scene already made that
sudden dark turn every mcu title has to
choose which parts of a character's
backstory to suddenly make important for
them in the next chapter and i just
can't wait to see the flashback scene in
the title i gag at the house of
heartness showing the heartbreaking
chapter in which wanda alone in her
cabin suddenly decides like all humans
sometimes do that our own needs
supersede everything else in our world
folks this whole mcu love it or hate it
is characterization across titles and
across media distribution formats and if
we can forgive tony stark for in the
same movie going from feeling so much
guilt over getting a kid killed to
binding his whole team to legislative
oversight who in the second act
endangering the child ultimate civil war
cooler we could certainly forgive wanda
for not embracing the quote what is
grief if not love persevering as her
mantra as much as we inked it as our
pandemic tattoos and now equally worthy
of our consideration is this film's
questions like how do we fill the holes
in our hearts is happiness truly the
highest pursuit now with everything in
this movie your mileage may vary which
is also the case when it comes to
whether multiverse madness is too
intense for you i will say that it is
safely pg-13 and no more violent than
episodes of what if were i mean that
show did repeatedly slaughter tony stark
and popped hulk
so you do you my final thoughts
multiverse of madness was not the film i
expected and i love it for that i was
shocked at how much marvel studios would
unleash sam raimi to wreak his madness
on the mcu toy box it is a bold vicious
thriller with images that will haunt me
forever no numerical score from me i'm
sorry it's just too early for me to
cement this movie's legacy just to give
haters or stands ammo to scream at each
other there's plenty of other real movie
critics for that i hope you enjoyed dr
strange's multiverse madness as much as
i did and once you see it send me your
thoughts follow me on twitter and
instagram at eavos following a rockstar
subscribing rockstar some more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]